et bien bonjour comment est-ce que ça va
aujourd'hui alors on va se parler
aujourd'hui de quoi on va se parler et
d'astuces le bonnes astuces de bonnes
pratiques pour l'iphone parce que ces
petites bêtes là c'est plutôt sympa
toujours des nouveautés des mises à jour
des nouvelles fonctionnalités qui arrive
et puis surtout il ya plein de
fonctionnalités déjà existantes qu'on ne
connaissait pas nécessairement donc on a
regardé pour en apprendre de nouvelles
pour optimiser ses usages pour savoir
faire plus de choses pour épater la
galerie et surtout pour se faire plaisir
donc on se regarde ça maintenant j'ai
combien je ne les ai pas content et j'ai
plein d'astuces pour bien utiliser votre
iphone et ça c'est bien un match
alors on va commencer par un truc qui
est assez marrant gros je sais pas si
vous êtes utilisateur tik tok d'ailleurs
si vous êtes sûr tik tok vous venez me
voir parce que j'ai un compte également
sur tik tok ça se passe juste la
regarder ça c'est mon compte tictoc on
est pour l'instant 80 unis lesquels tu
sais @ monsieur greu donc venez me voir
alors je vous montre un truc qui est
super cool l'idée c'est comment est ce
que je fais pour mettre une vidéo que
j'aime bien sûr tik tok de machette ou
d'une autre et bien comment est ce que
je fais pour mettre un compte
directement sur mon écran d'accueil de
mon iphone regardez la vidéo je vous
montre ça c'est marrant à l'antenne on
va choisir a forcé rien moi n'importe
quelle vidéo qui était marrante çà et là
par exemple sont de la box connectée est
bien gardé de faire quelque chose vous
venez juste ici sont les trois petits
points vous vous des cahiers son côté et
vous allez sur photos live photos live
ça fait quoi ça vient enregistrer la
vidéo directement dans votre iphone donc
là c'est en train de le convertir sa mue
en gîte directement de mon iphone une
fois je les offre je sors de là on vient
ici dans photo et dans photo regardez
vous retrouvez votre vidéo qui est la
fac c'est une vidéo mais qui sous forme
de photos dont voulait s'appuyer c'est
une photo live ont fait une fois que
vous êtes là vous allez ici d'en
partager on vient d'en utiliser en fond
d'écran alors ici blessé le lay photo
activé et vous désactivez la perspective
ok pas de perspective et un lay photo
qui est activé et vous faites définir et
vous mettez pour les deux ok et là il se
passe quoi vous venez vous laisser votre
doigt appuyé et vous avez votre vidéo
comme ça et là vous pouvez vous la péter
alors mettre une vidéo qui vous tient à
coeur une vidéo j'en sais rien moi des
premiers pas de votre enfant une vidéo
de mariage une vidéo d'anniversaire une
vidéo de soirée enfin un truc un peu
marrant de retrouver qui est sûre tictoc
on peut le mettre on peut le voir on
peut retrouver ça marche avec toutes les
lie photo vous allez pouvoir avoir c'est
du tic toc l'on peut faire avec d'autres
des souvenirs à vous qui vous
appartiennent je trouvais ça assez
marrant je voulais partager avec vous
autre astuce qui est super intéressant
lorsque vous voulez venir enregistrer un
email enregistré en pdf des documents de
voyage c'est pas des documents
importants dont on aura besoin plus tard
il bien les petites astuces pour mieux
le faire qui est extrêmement simple vous
venez dans vos emails ici par exemple
voyager un email qui est assez simple un
cul plutôt sympa c'est hadopi qui
veulent envoyer et bien ce que vous
faites regardez vous avez votre email
vous fait une capture d'écran up vous
revenez ici et vous mettez ici pleine
page donc là vous allez retrouver tout
votre email en plusieurs pages donc ça
c'est assez pratique je peux venir à
noter s'il ya un truc que je trouve
intéressant à tiens par exemple la
marque pour la france aujourd'hui
imaginer avec photoshop tiens regarde
dans cet email j'ai trouvé ça
intéressant je me fais des petites
flèches enfin bref je peux venir a noté
le truc est pratique et ensuite je fais
ok je vais enregistrer le pdf dans ce
fichier donc là je me crée un petit
dossier je vais mettre dans le registre
replace me fait un petit dossier test
j'enregistre je le mets dans mon dossier
test est dans mon dossier de le
retrouver ici hop là je lourd et là j'ai
mon pdf avec mes différents éléments que
j'ai annoté ça c'est assez pratique et
ensuite comme tout pdf là dessus je peux
venir le modifier l'éditer rajouter des
choses enfin bref c'est plutôt bien si
vous avez besoin d'enregistrer un email
en entier vous pouvez faire comme ça et
ça c'est cool je vous montrerai astuces
qui est assez marrante lorsque vous êtes
en train d'appeler quelqu'un que là vous
le mettez en silence donc là vous
appuyez il en silence mais si vous
voulez carrément le mettre en attente eh
bien regardez vous laissez votre doigt
appuyé quelques secondes ici et vous
passez de silence à attentes hélas la
personne est en attente après vous
appuyez-vous la laisser récupérer servi
en attente garder hop voulait s'appuyer
quelques secondes vous passez en attente
voilà la personne ni en attente c'est
une petite astuce c'est assez marrant
comme ça et il fallait le savoir une
astuce qui est vachement intéressante
vous recevez un sms vous copier ce sms
et de transférer dans une autre
discussion pour en envoyer quelqu'un
d'autre est malade et c'est vachement
simple que vous faites c'est vous prenez
ça hop là vous le prenez vous le
déplacer avec votre doigt vous venez
vous sortez de la conversation hop là
vous venez vous naviguez vous venez dans
une autre conversation il a regardé la
gelée toujours du bout du doigt je viens
ici je viens la glisser dans mon message
en bas et hop je lâche et là j'ai
retrouvé mon petit message dans une
autre conversation ça permet de faire un
glisser déposer c'est simple on pouvait
le faire avec du texte on peut le faire
et on peut le faire avec des photos on
peut également venir le faire avec un
sms ici pour transférer un sms reçu de
quelqu'un à quelqu'un d'autre ça peut
être pratiquée dans certains cas ça peut
être plutôt bien alors je sais pas ça
peut vous intéresser diplôme mois en bas
aux commentaires autre astuce qui est
super intéressante l'application photos
vous voulez venir chercher des photos
prises avec un certain modèle d'iphone
eh bien regardez c'est très simple vous
avez dans votre application et vous
venez d'en rechercher et vous allez
taper par exemple iphone il a regardé ça
vous propose là de toutes les photos
prises avec un certain modèle d'iphone
vais pouvoir me retrouver par exemple je
vais avoir quoi là je veux avoir un
iphone 6 est ce donc là j'ai toutes les
photos qui sont prises avec mon iphone 6
aces garde et notamment celle là la
belle tronche de vainqueur s'était pris
ça vous le marque là à central park et
il ya quoi il ya quatre ans tranche et
là je vais retrouver voyez mon modèle
l'iphone 6 s préféré que tous les
modèles d'iphone donc la regardait alors
que moi je teste beaucoup j'ai l'iphone
on se promet à ses fans disent pro mac
l'iphone 6 aces l'iphone 13 promax
l'iphone 10 aces mais j'ai aussi un
iphone 10 normalement j'ai trois photos
prises iphone dit ça y est c'est plus
des photos de vacances que je veux me
retrouver ici donc c'est plutôt sympa si
vous venez recherchez certaines photos
prises et que d'iphone vous dit ça je me
rappelle à cette époque de ma vie
j'avais tel iphone abacha c'est quoi
cette photo vous pouvez venir rechercher
par modèle et ça je trouve ça plutôt
intéressant si vous vous demandez
comment avoir cette icône là où une
hotte directement sur votre iphone je
vous montrais c'est très très simple en
fait ça c'est juste pour se marrer c'est
juste de la déconne c'est juste pour
faire bosser de la customisation que
vous allez avoir directement dans votre
smartphone hors jeu montre comment faire
enfin devenir vous la péter devant vos
amis et bien en fait ça ça vient du mode
concentration c'est un mode spécial que
j'ai créée alors je montre c'est le mode
fire montre comment créer le vôtre vous
venez ici et vous voulez dans le mode
concentration alors ici dans
concentration vous venez créer votre
propre mode vous faites quoi vous avez
plusieurs qui existe un vous venez créer
le vôtre avec l'icône que voulez vous
les dents personnalisé vous choisissez
l'icône qui vous intéresse alors moi
j'ai pris les colonnes de feu on peut le
dire qu'on va prendre les petits ciseaux
ça peut être marrant je les mets en
rouge on peut seulement être tendance
rouge lala qui en rouge qui peut être
encore plus si on va venir lui m en non
on va l'appeler on va l'appeler cut
voilà comme ça au pour cela fait un peu
au cut on l'a et ensuite on fait suivant
vous venez choisir les personnes qui
sont autorisées alors comme c'est un
truc pour faire beau on va autoriser
tout le monde vous venez autorisé tous
vos contacts vous cliquez là et vous
ajoutez tous vos contacts afin qu'ils
puissent tous de venir vous appelez sont
pas c'est-à-dire bloquer votre téléphone
donc là vous autorisez de la même
manière vous autoriser toutes les
applications que vous et qui viennent
nous contacter hop là nouveau mode de
concentration et ensuite vous venez
l'activé ici et vous allez retrouver vos
petits ciseaux en haut c'est efficace
c'est rigolo ça sert à rien ça n'a
strictement aucun intérêt mais je dois
reconnaître que c'est assez marrant et
que ça attire l'attention donc si vous
voulez venir vous la péter devant vos
potes on en a gardé une nouvelle
fonctionnalité que personne n'a
fonctionnalités ciseaux ou alors fait la
blague vous verrez qui se demanderont
comment le faire comment l'avoir ça fera
couler beaucoup d'encre tous à ses
rivaux voilà pour un fou autre astuce
qui est bien c'est comment ajouter une
application qui est dans votre
bibliothèque mais qui n'est pas sur un
de vos écrans d'accueil comme on l'a
jeté sur l'écran d'accueil c'est pas
extrêmement compliqué mais peut-être
vous ne le savez pas alors je vous
demande donc là effectivement moi j'ai
toutes mes applications qui vont être
classés par groupe mais regardez là j'ai
ma bibliothèque d'applications avec
pleins d'applications que je n'ai pas
retrouvé il ya ce qu'il faut faire c'est
extrêmement simple vous avez deux façons
de le faire vous voulez soit choisir et
bien les applications qui sont classés
par le groupe comme sa part donc
l'application djay il pas du tout dans
un de mes rangement elle n'est pas
classée elle et pas sur mon écran
d'accueil et de regarder je prends je
laisse appuyer dessus et je fais sur
l'écran d'accueil et elle arrivera sur
les écrans des comme ça c'est la
première chose sinon je vais dans la
bibliothèque d'applications ici je vais
avoir tout ma liste d'applications fait
pas un appui long directement sur le nom
de l'application ça ne marchera pas vous
faites un appui long directement sur
l'icône et là ça vient vous proposer sur
l'écran d'accueil vous pouvez donc y
ajouter directement sur votre écran
d'accueil si vous ne savez plus est une
application et sur l'écran d'accueil ou
pas bien vous mettez sur n'importe
laquelle fait un appui long et ça ne
vous propose pas ça veut dire qu'elle
est déjà sur l'écran d'accueil petites
astuces mais ça peut être pratique autre
astuce si comme moi vous avez beaucoup
d'onglets ouverts dans safari et vous
vous dites irda trop je sais plus quoi
correspond à quoi il faudrait les fermes
et que vous avez la flemme de venir les
femmes et manuellement et bien il ya une
petite fonctionnalité qui est très
simple qui existe regardez vous m'ont
déjà mois-ci vous faire marrer parce que
regarder moi par exemple ici et ben j'en
ai j'en ai je ne sais plus combien
aujourd'hui voilà j'ai 258 onglet s'est
regardé et chrissy 258 hong lei donc
voilà j'ai pas envie de faire m 138
onglets à la main ça me juge pas envie
voilà donc ce que je viens faire je vais
dans mes réglages je vais dans safari
alors regardez safari juste ici et dans
safari j'ai une petite société qui
s'appelle fermer les onglets alors soit
manuellement et c'est ce que j'ai ici
moi ce que je vous conseille de faire
est bien c'est de venir choisir délai de
fermeture ça vous fermez tout vos
onglets a pris un jour après une semaine
après un mois alors effectivement on
pourrait se dire j'ai des onglets
ouverts c'est plutôt intéressant
j'aimerais bien garder à ce moment là
venez les enregistrer directement dans
vos favoris comme ça vous pourrez avoir
accès à certaines pages qui vous
intéresse mais la plupart du temps quand
même à tout ça vous choisissez après une
semaine assez raisonnable après un mois
bon allez on va se mettre après une
semaine parce que ça sert à rien de tout
garder ouvert il ya un moment foyer où
ça fait quand même beaucoup d'anglais
autre astuce qui pourrait bien vous
sauver la vie c'est la question des
appels d'urgence lorsqu'il vous arrive
un problème vous êtes tombé vous êtes
dans un accident vous êtes cassé la
patte mais vous cherchez un moyen rapide
pour appeler les secours que vous pouvez
juste appuyer mais que vous sentez pas
d'aller dans le téléphone c'est
compliqué et bien regarder les petites
astuces vous montre vous venez dans vos
réglages et dans vos réglages vous allez
sur appel d'urgence qui est situé juste
ici et là il faut venir faire quoi il
faut venir activé appel avec 5 appuie
donc ça vous l'actionner et vous le mark
si vous appuyez rapidement cinq fois sur
le bouton latéral compte à rebours se
lancer une alerte et élise à l'issue du
compte à rebours l'iphone appelle les
secours donc ça veut dire quoi le fait
cinq fois un deux trois quatre cinq
appels d'urgence voyez ça va appeler
alors ici je veux pas appeler les
urgences ont vibré tout vous entendez
bon on est quand même prévenu alors je
viens l'arrêté ici parce que je suis pas
là pour rappeler faire un appel
d'urgence mais cette fonctionnalité
existe et je trouve extrêmement
rassurante vous appuyez cinq fois en
votre petit bouton on off et s'appellera
allégeance et si vous le faites dans
votre poche par accident ça va venir
sonner donc vous le saurez donc soyez
tranquilles disait là dessus autre
astuce qui me paraissait logique plutôt
bien en termes de confidentialité c'est
de savoir quelle application va utiliser
votre micro mais utilisez votre caméra
alors effectivement aujourd'hui sur un
os avec une petite icône lorsqu'une
application est en train de l'utiliser
mais néanmoins on n'a pas forcément avec
toutes les applications et ses
autorisations donc ce qu'il faut venir
faire vous allez ici dans vos réglages
et vous allez dans confidentialité et
dans confidentialité gardez vous l'avez
ici vous avez le micro vous avez
l'appareil photo et on va regarder qui
peut venir utiliser un micro alors j'ai
pleins d'applications et raiola qui ont
un sens un corner de guitare il le faut
amazon avait que ça aussi l'assistant
club house bouquet lien est certaine
j'ai plus du tout envie qu'elle utilise
ward utilise pages débats jazz le venir
le désactiver match aller des cochers il
ya un côté des fois un peu rassurant
même si de toute façon on sait très bien
qu'avec les iphone quand une application
va venir utiliser votre micro ou votre
appareil photo et bien vous le verrez en
or des fois on n'a pas forcément envie
mais bon des fois on préférera le faire
manuellement et ça a un sens que ce soit
au niveau du micro ce sont les fautes
plus haut niveau de l'appareil photo
boyer typiquement ça pouvait le faire
autre astuce est vachement importante
c'est au niveau des notifications je
trouve que les notifications quelque
chose d'extraordinaire parce que l'on
sait à quel moment quelqu'un vous envoie
un message ans et plein de choses mais
c'est aussi une source de pollution une
source de déconcentration c'est une
source de stress donc des fois on n'a
pas envie d'avoir tout si fication alors
on peut se mettre dans certains modes
notamment le votre concentration
certaines applications ne vous enverra
pas de notification mais des fois on a
envie de pouvoir recevoir un message
important mais ne pas savoir si
quelqu'un a leaké votre photo ou amis un
commentaire ou ce qu'il faut venir faire
du vin gardez vous allez ici dans
notification et dans notification il
faut venir activer un truc qui
s'appellera le résumé programmée alors
regardez hop vous venez vous l'actionner
je voulais laisser comme ça pour vous
puissiez bien le voir en fait vous
regrouper les notifications non urgentes
et vous les recevez dans un résumé
hauser qui vous conviennent vous
programmez la distribution et vous
manquez surtout absolument rien donc on
va se configurer donc on vient ici ils
vous marquent un choisissez les
applications à inclure les messages
directs et les notifications urgentes ne
sont pas concernées car elles sont
toujours distribuées immédiatement
envoyé par exemple hop là je le dis à la
petite toque le monde facebook peut on
afficher plus donc l'âge d'or toutes mes
applications où je vois que j'ai
beaucoup de notification et bien
regarder comme ça j'ai la main dessus
qu'est ce que je vais me dire qu'ils
m'ont va beaucoup de notification
instagram qui m'envoient des motifs la
twitter donc là je veux acheter c'est à
ces cinq applications et là je veux
commencer par définir un programme aussi
choisissez les heures auxquelles vous
souhaitez recevoir un résumé de
notification alors le premier résumé à
je peux le vouloir le matin et puis un
deuxième résumé le soir à 18h et puis le
reste du temps je vais te pena et
ensuite je fais quoi eh bien je fais
activer le résumé de notification donc
là je retrouve ensuite ici directement
dans les paramètres je peux ajouter des
heures et si et ça je peux afficher le
prochain résumé ici afficher le prochain
résumé dans le centre de notification
avant l'heure prévue ok bon uniquement
de l'absence de notification on va pas
se le dire donc la voyez une fois de
plus je vais avoir mes différentes
applications je vois le nombre de
notifications que je vais recevoir stoke
ne t'aime pas mal et ensuite il ya un
truc qui va sûrement intéressant je vais
dans une application par exemple pas
derrière va se faire quoi on va aller
sur un petit instagram alors instagram
là je vais avoir une émission de
notification distribution immédiate pour
chaque application je te dis ah bah ça
va être distribuée sur les médiateurs
lui qui distribue effectivement et je
vois les horaires et une fois de plus
peut venir modifier le programme est la
nôtre qui est vachement bien c'est les
messages directs alors regardez les
notifications de messages directs ont
toujours immédiatement distribuée en
dehors des résumés programmé ça veut
dire que si quelqu'un vous envoie un
message un dm et bien je le recevrai
mais si je veux pas d'oedème si je veux
pas être embêté et hop je décoche et là
j'en aurai pas on a vraiment la main
dessus ça évite d'être complètement
submergé de notification c'est notamment
le cas de personnes comme moi qui
travaillons sur les réseaux sociaux hors
fraudes
notification et puis un moment c'est un
peu anxiogène donc voilà on peut venir
faire ça comme ça on garde les messages
aux côtés de notification et voit plus
tard et sinon et si je veux savoir je
vais sur l'application mais c'est moi
qui décide et je garde la main donc ça
c'est cool autre astuce est plutôt cool
je vous montrais je sais pas si vous la
connaissez si venir faire un copier
coller à trois doigts alors on fait
comment ça se passe balageas sur une
photo par exemple et je veux dire elle a
copié pour la mettre dans une note parce
qu'on met 3 droit et regarder en up je
pense comme ça elle y copier ça me
marque en outre pas si vous le voyez
bien et ensuite j'aime ouvrir une note
une note qui vierge et je fais quoi je
pose mes doigts et les écarts trois
doigts j'écarte et ça me colle donc la
voyez ça m'a marqué alors je vais la
supprimer pour vous montrer hop là trois
doigts collés ça c'est vachement bien
nés après il ya une haute fonction qui
existent année je vais vous montrer par
exemple comment on peut le faire avec
trois doigts ici dans une note donc là
je prends ma note je sélectionne alors
je peux le faire soit directement après
avec les raccourcis soit avec mes doigts
à plat regard des peuples à copier hop
il deuxième fois ça me fais couper donc
ça me le coût copier couper et ensuite
trois doigts jeu rijkaard collé collé
collé collé collé voyez si je veux collé
collé si je veux beaucoup collet si je
suis un serial kohler et ben je peux
coller autant de fois que je veux alors
après tout c'est que ça bouge c'est pas
toujours très pratique mais on peut
venir coller voilà donc là je viens
collet je suis un soir jan koller que je
crois que tu colles de tous les côtés
donc voilà c'est quand il y en a 12 12
10 et 2 ça fait douze astuces pour votre
iphone je sais pas si vous les
connaissiez s'il y en a certaines que
vous connaissez d'autres que vous ne
connaissiez pas dites le moi d'ailleurs
en bas en commentaire comment est ce que
vous trouvez ces astuces et ce qu'elle
vous intéresse c'est ce que vous
voudriez qu'on fasse d'autres vidéos
d'astuces comme ça où je donne des
bonnes astuces des bonnes pratiques
alors ici on parle d'iphone mais ya pas
que des iphone on peut le faire je
voulais faye a pas longtemps sur xiaomi
je vous ai montré également des
chaussures des smartphones de samsung on
peut le faire pourquoi pas sur un
smartphone de huawei on peut le faire
sur un smartphone de one voice on peut
le faire sur un smartphone de pompage
gens sont beaucoup de smartphones dites
moi ça vous intéresse en bas en
commentaire et si vous avez vous aussi
vos astuces vous pouvez les donner juste
en bas dans les commentaires on se
retrouve très vite pour parler de take 2
nouveautés on va faire des thèses de
tous les côtés et ça s'est tellement
chouette vous embrasse pour les
rendez-vous des bisous
[Musique]